lots of irregularities going on in the
vote count in pennsylvania michigan
wisconsin arizona we'll go through a
number of them on the show but you
remember even starting on election night
certain key counties
would just stop counting some of them
have stopped counting
for days at a time all extremely suspect
but the main charge right now against
democrats among people who think
maybe there are some problems with this
vote count the main charge
is that democrats are stuffing ballot
boxes
and even though we're talking about a
lot of new things that have never
happened in elections before
stuffing ballot boxes is an american
tradition that goes back
to the earliest days of our republic in
fact a
sitting president democratic president
once taught a future democratic
president
how to do it and how to prevent it we'll
get into all of it i'm michael knowles
that's the michael knowles show
welcome back my favorite comment from
yesterday is from
god so loved who says pollsters like the
news media are just another propaganda
arm of the democrats
this is true but it's not true exactly
in the way
that people might think the pollsters
got this election completely wrong there
is no reason to listen to these
pollsters anymore
but pollsters have gotten other
elections right and i'm not saying
they're awful terrible people or
anything i'm not even saying they set
out
to lie maybe some of them do but but
others don't
the reason that the polls are wrong the
reason that the polls are part of the
same propaganda wing as the democrats
is because they're part of the whole
progressive system
when progressivism rose up about a
century a little more than a century ago
now i guess
it rose up with the modern university in
the social sciences
and public opinion polling and
statistics statistics itself referring
to the state
meaning matters of the state referring
to the modern state the administrative
state the progressive state
all of these things are part of the same
system and so when the system is working
very well
they all kind of work well together but
when that system stops reflecting
reality when that system
starts to break down then the polling
starts to break down
too and i think we are seeing that
system begin to crumble this election is
in many ways
an attack that system that establishment
striking back trying to preserve itself
after donald trump
swung a sledgehammer into it and that
might prevail joe biden who is the
system he is just the
the face the avatar of the system he he
may prevail
for a while i don't know maybe for a
long while but he may not and i'm very
glad that
president trump is fighting back about
that there is so much
talk going on there was so much chatter
about what's happening in in the
individual states and in the individual
precincts and if you want to talk very
well especially to your friends in
pennsylvania michigan wisconsin you've
got to get pure talk usa
what if there were a company that gave
you an amazing deal every single day
that is what you get with puretalk a
veteran run wireless company
think at t but much much better this
company understands what it means to
serve if you're using verizon att mobile
you are overpaying for for your service
you can get the same
coverage for much less now i know you
think that i'm saying you could get
similar coverage for much less i'm not
saying that
i'm saying you could get the exact same
coverage for much much less pure talk
can easily save you
over 400 a year all you need unlimited
talk text and two gigs of data for just
20 bucks a month
and if you go over on data usage they
don't charge you they do not charge you
switching to pure talk is the easiest
decision you will make today
grab your phone and you get to keep your
number
or you can get great deals on the latest
iphones
and android head on over there right now
to pure talk usa grab your phone dial
pound 250 say michael knowles
m-i-c-h-a-e-l-k-n w-l-e-s
when you do you'll save 50 off your
first month dal pound 2 5 0
and say key word michael knowles pure
talk is simply smarter wireless
i was reminded of this story not a lot
of people
remember it that's in one of uh former
president lyndon johnson's biographies
lyndon johnson was a crook this guy had
been stealing elections since college he
would steal student government elections
then when he was a staffer on the hill
there was a club called the little
congress this was for congressional
staffers
they they elected a president every year
he stole that election too this is a
meaningless club other staffers on the
hill said could you believe somebody
would steal
the presidency of the little congress
this guy was a crook
then in 1941 lyndon johnson runs for
senate
he's running against coke stevenson in
the democratic primary in texas whoever
wins the primary
is going to go on and or no i'm sorry
this was actually he ran against cook
stevenson about
seven years later this is 1941 he's
running for senate
and he loses he loses the 1941 raise
because the other guy stuffed the ballot
box so he was uh
friends with franklin roosevelt who was
then the president of the united states
and roosevelt was a sort of patron of
lyndon johnson
and and roosevelt asked to speak to him
and the two men talked
about the race and franklin roosevelt
said
lyndon apparently you texans haven't
learned one of the first things we
learned up in new york state
and that is that when the election is
over you have to sit on the ballot boxes
now what fdr is saying to lyndon johnson
it's not necessarily corrupt he's not
saying
you got to stuff the ballot boxes but
he's saying
whatever happens to the ballot box once
the election is over you got to sit on
them
so that your opponent can't stuff that
ballot box so that no
illegal votes can get in this is 1941
and then then in the senate race uh
between
lyndon johnson and coke stevenson in
1948 johnson did stuff that ballot box
with 202
illegal votes this went all the way up
to the supreme court but the supreme
court refused to get involved here this
was a race
of 1 million people lyndon johnson won
it by 87 votes
and 202 of those votes we now know with
certainty were fraudulent in that race
all of that is to say if somebody is
going to call you
a lunatic or a conspiracy theorist or
anything like that
because you raise the possibility given
a fair bit of evidence that there are
irregularities in voting particularly
with inflated numbers
you should laugh in their face this is
going on a long time in this country
two democratic presidents joked about it
with one another
and a trick here is that you got to sit
on the ballot box
it's not just about turning out your
guys to vote i i know the trump campaign
did a great job and get out the vote
if the trump supporters show up to vote
then you're going to win
you've also got to sit on the ballot box
and what what happened on election night
was that multiple crucial counties in
the country
just stopped counting why
i don't know i don't know we're getting
reports in it that in certain places
this wouldn't be enough to swing the
election but it would be enough to
change the vote count if it happened in
multiple places votes are being reported
off by an order of magnitude when people
are reporting them so they've been fixed
in some places
how many places have they not been fixed
we know in georgia there's illegal
ballots going on
a republican poll observer in georgia
saw 53
late absentee ballots illegally added to
a stack of on-time absentee ballots
in chatham county and the republican
official
says that we will not allow democrat
officials to steal this election from
trump with late illegal ballots
it depends on the state but in certain
states like georgia if the ballot comes
in
late it cannot count now what the
democrats will say is we want every vote
to count that's the joe biden campaign
we need every vote to count and they
make something of an argument right it's
a
heartstrings argument to say every vote
in america every voice has to count
but there are rules to elections if i go
vote right now
well especially if i go vote because i'm
a republican then my vote won't count
but
of course it shouldn't count if you're
voting days after the election your vote
should not count but that was
the the thought process here among
democratic officials i
guarantee i bet the forum on it if you
delay
the count more votes can come in and
that's what republican poll watchers are
seeing
happen in georgia another
irregularity that's going on you saw
this in wisconsin
is a major major voter surge so voter
turnout
with 98 of precincts reporting shows
that nearly nine out of 10 registered
voters
cast ballots 89 of wisconsin voters cast
ballots
now wisconsin does have same-day
registration but we don't have the same
day registration numbers
so we don't know how that number is and
i can just tell you
as a matter of elections 89 percent is
an
implausible voter turnout number that
does not happen
it's usually closer to around 60 percent
maybe
maybe you can tick up higher sometimes
it's even lower than that
now we're trying to pretend it's 89 that
is
statistically impossible now with
same-day voter registration maybe the
numbers i don't know 77 78
that is still implausible very difficult
to believe
think about this president trump got
something like 5 million extra votes
this year than he did in 2016.
that doesn't happen in re-election years
barack obama got millions fewer
votes in 2012 than he did in 2008.
president trump gets something like 5
million more votes and it's still not
enough
very difficult to believe that i suppose
it could be true but it's very difficult
to believe that now speaking of the poll
watchers at every election this is why
we have election day by the way
and why voting before election day is
not legitimate
in in very narrow circumstances if you
can't leave if you have an absentee
ballot
perhaps exceptions prove rules but
election day exists for a reason
because people try to commit fraud and
in michigan the poll watchers
are not even being given access to the
count so the reason that
both campaigns have poll watchers to
make sure people aren't cheating
in in certain parts of michigan the
trump campaign poll watchers can't even
get in
what's going on there very difficult for
me to believe that that's a fair count
if they're not letting them in in other
places in this country you saw election
officials
putting boards up on windows so that the
public could not look in
and see the vote count what's going on
there
i point to these individual
irregularities
because one of them if it were just one
in isolation that would not be enough to
say
there's something illegitimate going on
but when you add them all
up we can only touch on a handful on
this show when you add them all
up you have to start wondering what
is going on here how about skewed
election results in michigan also in
michigan michigan crucial state
that was going heavily for trump then
you know you wait a few days and
i don't know something's changing now
it's more of a democrat state
the antrim county clerk cheryl guy
became aware of skewed results in the
unofficial election result tabulations
so early morning this is yesterday early
morning unofficial result results
showed single digit returns in the
presidential race
for donald trump in townships including
estonia echo helena
and torch lake with 65 to 80 reporting
so you're telling me there's gonna be
six or seven votes
in those townships for donald trump i
don't believe that
antrum county is a republican stronghold
it has been for a very long time
but then in certain precincts there joe
biden and other democratic candidates
had many many many more votes than
normal
this is according to a former michigan
state lawmaker quote it just looked
weird
two-thirds of the townships looked
really messed up
now you don't need to take my word for
it this isn't just some
conservative observer a conservative
activist a conservative politician even
this is the
county clerk penny clerk's saying
something is really wrong here something
stinks
we know plenty stinks in pennsylvania
something seems to stink in michigan too
but speaking of pennsylvania consider
this this is from 538 by the way this is
nate silver's outfit which i don't
remember i think the last time they
predicted an election correctly
was 2008 with barack obama it's the
whole reason 538 started
but for some reason everyone pays
attention and nate silver is this great
genius
nate silver says two more batches of
pennsylvania votes were reported
around 23 277 votes in philadelphia
all for biden all forbidden 23
277 votes and then
5300 votes in lucerne county four
thousand of which were for biden
so even that number four thousand out of
fifty three hundred very difficult to
believe
but it's extremely difficult for me to
believe that twenty three thousand two
hundred seventy to seven votes in philly
we're
all 100
for joe biden i don't know that we can
quite believe that
and then this brings us to north
carolina
north carolina as far as i'm concerned
the biggest issue of all
we got results out of florida which is
usually a very contested
pla state right florida was the reason
we had the 38 day recount for bush v
gore
we got results out of ohio another
contested state
that was fine all on election night we
get results we've gotten results now out
of west coast states
states in the middle of the country all
on election night or shortly thereafter
but north carolina polls closed very
early there east coast state
north carolina trump doing very very
well in
we don't have the numbers nbc news is
estimating that about 300 000 votes are
left
to be but north carolina first of all
why couldn't north carolina count the
votes
we don't know but north carolina's
not even counting them anymore north
carolina did not count those
ballots yesterday they just stopped
north carolina
says that they will not give us a number
until november 12th
november 12th what day is it today the
fifth
what's taking so long north carolina
what are you all doing
you might suggest that one of the
reasons that north carolina's
data why their numbers aren't going to
come in until so late
is because if joe biden gets into
trouble it would certainly help joe
biden to win north carolina i don't know
i'm not proposing that
what i do know is ballot box stuffing
is an undeniable american tradition and
specifically an undeniable
democratic party tradition there is
nothing conspiratory well there is
someone conspiratorial about that it's a
conspiracy to do it but it's happened
for a long time in this country
the other thing is that it's not just
one
irregularity or two irregularities i
want to make sure that i don't sound
like democrats in 2016 when i'm raising
questions
about some of these numbers democrats in
2016 said this is an illegitimate
election
i said why is that they said because
russia
i said what did russia do they i don't
know they did something
okay we had an investigation into that
by the way russia bought a hundred
thousand dollars worth of facebook ads
some of which were four democrats by the
way
so that claim was ridiculous but here
we've got a lot of questions
shutting down the counting delaying the
counting until november third in north
carolina
the multiple reports of ballot stuffing
the multiple reports of republican poll
watchers
not being allowed to look at the results
the issue of sharpies in arizona that
may
raise questions over whether ballots
could be counted this was in republican
strongholds apparently election
officials passed out
sharpies instead of pens sharpies there
were some questions as to whether or not
they could be counted now arizona saying
they could be counted
who knows who knows all of these issues
and we haven't even scratched the
surface
raised questions about this process to
say nothing of widespread unsolicited
mail-in ballots which are
which are truly unprecedented in this
country and rife for fraud the reason we
have poll watchers in the first place
is because there is so much opportunity
for fraud and the left is not going to
admit that
if the numbers just keep miraculously
ticking up
in their favor very important to keep
your data secure
this is true on the political level it's
from the personal level okay we have
news of another cyber attack here
this time the victim is barnes and noble
the breach potentially exposed
customer data here uh this is not a very
good thing you're going to want to make
sure that you don't lose your email
addresses billing shipping addresses
telephone numbers transaction histories
the attack also impacted
nook and ebook services some customers
have been unable to access their nook
libraries
their previous purchases have
disappeared and others were unable to
log
into the firm's online platform lifelock
helps detect
a wide range of identity threats like
social security numbers for sale on the
dark web
if they detect your information has
potentially been compromised they will
send you
an alert make sure you use lifelock okay
i know it seems like this kind of idea
that
listen nobody's coming for my dad and
nobody's coming for my stuff
they are they are and a little bit of
prevention is worth a pound of cure
no one can prevent all identity theft or
monitor all transactions at all
businesses
lifelock can see threats that you might
miss on your own join now and save up to
twenty five percent off your first year
go to lifelock.com knowles knwles that
is lifelock
dot com slash knowles k w l e s for 25
off the good news is president trump is
filing lawsuits
in basically all of these states the
trump campaign filed lawsuits in
pennsylvania michigan and georgia
laying the groundwork for contesting
battleground states as he started to
fall behind joe biden because you'll
notice if you look at the
electoral account somehow joe biden's
numbers just keep going up and we don't
know why and it's all
away from the public light when we were
all watching the election on election
night when there were all those eyeballs
there
trump was winning but then when people
started to look away
and the system took over again somehow
joe biden
started doing much much better these new
filings join existing republican legal
challenges in pennsylvania and nevada
they demand better access for campaign
observers to where the ballots are being
processed and counted
where the absentee ballots are being
counted
what does president trump have to do
here president trump needs to make sure
not just that all the votes are counted
president trump needs to make sure that
all of the votes are verified
okay in that in that election in 1948
when lbj stole the senate seat
they found 202 ballots that were
illegitimate they were all written in
the same pen they were all written
in the same handwriting and the people
who allegedly had voted
said they never voted that day we're
getting some this is just anecdotal but
we're hearing from some people in
wisconsin who called to find out if
their votes have been counted they said
they haven't been counted yet
it's pretty strange these are just
republicans i'm talking to it might be a
selection bias
or might not be a selection bias by the
way they called arizona on election
night
for biden actually when i say they i
should be more specific
fox news called arizona on election
night for joe biden this was very very
early
and no one else had done it and it was
very strange because fox news is
supposed to be the conservative cable
outlet so you think you would think okay
if someone's going to call it for biden
that early it's going to be msnbc or cnn
but it wasn't
now we're finding out whoopsy daisy
actually there were many fewer votes
that had come in in arizona than we were
told on election night actually arizona
may still be up for grabs there's a data
firm in arizona right now
data orbital which is saying that uh
president trump is on track to win in
arizona which backs up claims
by the trump campaign that actually this
is far from over
the decision to call arizona on election
night was perplexing to a lot of people
because it really set trump back in
terms of the media narrative and
there seemed to be no reason for it it
looked like a preposterous and
irresponsible call
why was it i mean you actually had hosts
and correspondents from that network
openly criticizing it on air saying what
is going on guys what
are you doing i don't know i don't i'm
not going to speculate on what's going
on over there
but this is a major issue if you've got
even the the
ostensibly right-wing cable network now
doing more work for the left-wing
groups than even the left-wing networks
you've got protests right now
outside of the maricopa county elections
office in arizona
and the protesters are extraordinarily
angry about the state being called
a lot of people in the crowd are are not
wearing masks we're
we're keeping a respectful distance but
a loud
and very boisterous crowd you'll start
hearing them
start up here
and they're actually chanting fox news
sucks fox news sucks the reason why
they're chanting that is because fox
news
called arizona for biden yesterday
and a lot of people are angry about that
we have not called
arizona a lot of other so msnbc
obviously very
gleeful to be announcing that they're
they're chanting against their
competitor although i guess fox really
isn't a competitor at nbc
or msnbc they're completely different
audiences what's interesting though at
the top of that clip is he walks out and
he says
they're not wearing masks they're not
social distancing like and now protests
are bad
is that right after eight months of blm
and antifa burning the country down and
protesting for whatever
cause they want to protest usually on
false evidence now protests are bad that
we're talking about our election
i think i think those protests are
pretty justified
but people are very very upset about
this
and what's what seems to be happening is
what the left
i would say predicted but i think really
promised is a better word the
left promised us that trump was going to
win the election on election day
but then they were going to somehow come
out winning the vote later on
they were going to call they called it a
red mirage the mirage is all the people
are going to vote for you and you're
going to see it with your own eyes but
then don't worry
later on we're gonna win they all seem
so confident don't you worry we're gonna
win
here is msnbc's joy reid discussing how
the red mirage turns out
and i think partly because even though
we knew the red wave was a thing
and then the red mirage i should say the
red mirage we all knew it was coming
but when you're right in the moment it
is it's innervating
it's it's aggravating and i think partly
and i said this last night i do think
it's because
we've been reporting for five years
rachel about
russia about national security you know
just just undermining our national
security
you know the impeachment on the racism
the nazis
all of it and been coveted laying on top
of it
felt like a repudiation was coming and i
think even though we intellectually
understand what america
is at its base right that there is a
great amount of racism anti-blackness
anti-wokeness this idea that political
correctness is some sort of
scheme to destroy white america right
like we know
what this country is but you still part
of you i think part of your
your heart says you know what maybe the
country is gonna pay
pay off all of this pain the children
were stolen
with a repudiation so you hear first of
all how much the left despises this
country
just the way they speak we know what
this country is we know what it is it's
awful and
you know what they've got to do they've
got to vote for democrats to pay off the
pain and injustice of this country
lady give me a break it's the greatest
country on earth
this woman is spouting her stupid
nonsense on tv she's extremely wealthy
she's treated extremely well she's
treated better by the law
than people basically any country on
earth
give me a break lady
but this is what they think the left
hates the country
i don't know how else to put it i know
it sounds extreme but she just said it
you heard it with her own ears she goes
this country they've got to pay off all
the pain and the
damage and the injustice they've caused
no no the country doesn't have to pay
off anything lady it's the best country
on earth
get over yourself i'm sorry that you're
upset about some imaginary
problem while you pontificate on
television
and count your stacks of money but
and and feel safe in your personhood and
your property
and in your political liberties i'm
sorry that you're that upsets you
where else would you like to go what's
what country is better off give me a
break
but they don't like the country and you
heard at the top you heard at the top
she says
we have a red mirage we knew it was
going to come the red mirage had to come
and then the
red mirage is coming i think she
believes this i think this is a
self-fulfilling prophecy
i i think this is an article of faith
for the left
you always hear the left talking about
how we have to defend democracy but it's
ironic because the democrats are the
people who most
undermine democracy you saw this in
2016. maybe who knows maybe you're
seeing it now but you certainly saw it
in 2016.
the people like donald trump and then
they tried to not even make that a
possibility because the deep state
was spying on the trump campaign but
then trump gets elected
and they try to have a coup d'etat for
three and a half years now how is this
possible
how are the democrats in the name of
democracy undermining democracy
because for the democrats in their world
it is only legitimate to elect democrats
that's the only that is the only way an
election can be legitimate
and it is actually it is actually worth
it
to steal an election like they tried to
do in 2016 and who knows what's going on
now
it is worth it but we we know for a fact
but that they tried to do it in 2016.
it is worth it to try to steal an
election
in the name of democracy a stolen
election that elects democrats is more
legitimately democratic
for democrats than a legitimate election
that elects republicans
how's that for a tongue twister but
that's how they think about this
and and what's so crazy to me about the
whole thing
she's talking about the racism of trump
the
the russians and the nazis and all this
the the idea that there are kgb agents
and nazis running around america right
now
is preposterous right i mean that's a
pure fantasy
the idea that donald trump is a racist
preposterous pure fantasy
but this she says this is what we know
about the country
that's that's but now we're seeing now
joe biden hopefully will be elected
that's what we that's what we want to
see
of course those might be flipped in
terms of their fantasies
and their reality the really sad thing
about it though is is this whole
experience reminded me
getting back to the protests in arizona
there
is no conservative outlet in the legacy
media
there is no conservative institution in
the political establishment there's not
one in the whole country
and there were some that i i certainly
thought were conservative
i used to think we're conservative
in i don't know in the established
higher education and they established
even technology some places in corporate
america in
and of course in the the legacy news
media i thought okay there's one
one or two no there's not
there are court jesters in the kingdom
of liberalism there are some
conservative institutions that sort of
pretend
they pretend to be conservative
institutions but then when push comes to
shove
and when the leftist hegemony is
threatened they fold
they fold up and they play their part
and they they act the fool
and they in in many ways legitimize the
reigning left-wing
regime the liberal regime by pretending
that there's some disagreement here but
there's not
and what president trump did was he
offered and
and continues to offer i hope a
legitimate alternative
to that you had essentially one
political party
in recent decades until trump you had
party that
basically agreed on foreign policy
obama's foreign policy was not very much
different than george bush's foreign
policy
they basically agreed on global trade
obama's foreign policy was not really
different than bush's foreign policy or
mccains or romney's
they basically agree on immigration
obama's immigration policy
was not very different than mccain's or
romney's or george bush's
or bush the first for that matter they
all agreed on these big questions and
then on certain cultural issues they
kind of
the conservatives would kind of pretend
to disagree but then they'd just roll
over that's why we've lost all of those
issues
over the years there was basically one
party and then trump comes in and
everyone just focuses on his personality
but what really distinguishes trump are
the issues
he opposed their liberal global trade
regime
he opposed their liberal open borders
immigration regime
he opposed their liberal administrative
state
deep state bureaucracy whatever you want
to call it governing regime
just those three things would be enough
such that the system cannot permit him
to get elected again and perhaps the
system won't
who knows who knows there will be legal
challenges to this
maybe joe biden won the election
outright maybe
i guess in that way the result could be
a legitimate result
but what we do know for sure is that
this process
has been far from it this process has
had so many irregularities
just the unprecedented unsolicited
widespread mail-in ballots alone are
enough to raise questions but then you
find out
poll workers poll watchers not allowed
in
numbers getting corrected sometimes and
people catch it
the process itself raises a lot a lot of
questions raises my hair makes it stand
on in luckily i have here though did you
know that two out of three guys
will experience some form of male
pattern baldness by the time they're 35
the best way to prevent hair loss is to
do something about it while you still
have hair left
prevention is key keeps treatments
typically take between four to six
months to see results
so it is important to act fast the
sooner you start using keeps
the more hair you will save find out why
keeps has more five star reviews than
any of its competitors
and more than one hundred thousand men
trust keeps for their hair loss
prevention medication
keeps treatment start at just ten
dollars per month plus
for a limited time you can get your
first month for free you know that i am
not
a hulking adonis necessarily of a man
but i always did well in the lady
department i have always chalked that up
to my hair make sure
that you get to keep the hair that you
have it's a very small investment
for a very big payoff if you're ready to
take action
and prevent hair loss go to keeps.com
knowles to receive your first month of
treatment for free that is k-e-e-p-s
dot slash knowles k-n-o-w-l-e-s
things have never been crazier over here
folks make sure that you subscribe to
the michael knowles show youtube channel
and make sure you head on over subscribe
to daily wire we'll be right back with
the mailbag
all right my first question from patrick
dear michael with people voting
a month or two months ahead how many of
them will die before the election
that's an interesting question will
their votes be considered legal votes by
dead people will these votes be
disqualified
or will they automatically be switched
to democrat well it is true that
democrats lost a lot among the black
vote they lost a lot among the hispanic
vote
they lost they lost a lot among key
demographics for them but they've always
held firm on the dead vote
dead people vote for democrats 100 of
the time
you know we've raised some questions
about how
the uh the vote will turn out you know
among
these these numbers that come in 100 for
biden you know 99 for biden even saddam
hussein had
the common decency to lower his election
returns to 97
or something but the one group that
always votes 100 for democrats
are dead people this this does raise a
real question though that the fact that
we had such early voting the fact that
that on google one of the top trends
after the second debate was how can i
change my
vote or at least a surging trend on
google was how can i change my vote
this this shows you the weakness of
early voting i mean
there's the fraud issue but there's also
just a basic issue that
the election campaigns are geared toward
a specific date that's election day
new information comes out until then and
you should not
vote the people should not vote until
all of that information has come out now
if you live in a system that has early
voting i guess you can take advantage of
it
you don't want to unilaterally disarm
but as a rule it's it's very bad and it
does
favor democrats from christina
hello michael during this election i
took notice of the counties within each
state
i noticed that states that went blue
look more red than blue when viewed by
county
for example virginia and new york i
understand that large cities such as dc
and new york
have a role in why they turn blue
i can imagine it is frustrating for
those living outside the cities
to have their voices be drowned out by
the city folk my question is would
states ever use an electoral college god
bless
i've lived in new york i've worked in
politics in new york new york
is split 50-50 between
the democrats and republicans sort of
but
but it's skewed a little bit i guess in
the direction of democrats but
the state itself is split
with upstate new york which
geographically takes up i don't know 95
of new york and the city
then you have long island too but the
city is very very tiny on the map
and yet you've got what 12 million
voters there
more even at this point so that's the
the way the place breaks up
i suppose that's fair because you know
you don't give votes to mountains and
trees you give votes to people and there
are just fewer people upstate even
though the space is much much larger
but there is a big cultural difference
here between the city
and the country that tension has always
existed cities have always been more
liberal the country has always been more
conservative i don't see any world in
which there would be a mechanism
to give greater power to the country
folk because the thing is that the
places are
dominated by the cities so the city
people are never going to give up their
power
so i think that will fall apart as it is
but it does raise a lot of questions
does somebody in upstate new york
have more in common with manhattan or
with pennsylvania
obviously pennsylvania no question about
that
so i don't know you're seeing a
balkanization of the country you're
seeing
people in blue states move to red states
we're about to do that at the daily wire
tomorrow or something like later this
week um
but you may see that in the in the
various states within the states as well
which is there is an ex-urbanization
there had been years and years and years
of urbanization now people are leaving
and they're leaving because
there's nothing to do in the cities
anymore i love new york it's my favorite
city in the world
you couldn't pay me to live in new york
right now because the whole point of new
york is you live in
tiny little squalor you pay thousands of
dollars a month to live in a shoebox
and every day is garbage day and there's
rats everywhere but
there's all this fun stuff great
restaurants great bars
great clubs great everything right so
you
you put up with it well during the
lockdowns
all those fun things closed in new york
you live in a shoebox because the whole
city is your living room
but it's not during coven so that
exacerbated that right now they're
suspecting that most restaurants in new
york will go out of business
very sad new york institutions the
roosevelt
hotel just announced this one of the
real landmarks
going out of business they're out um
some of i mean it's heartbreaking to see
it
so you couldn't pay me to live there and
it's true even for people
who love those cities you know and still
live there
they're moving out that might spread out
the vote a little bit more
from sam hey michael since you're a
devout catholic i should pause here i
always prefer the term practicing
catholic
because i'm going to keep on practicing
until i get it right you know the term
devout
i don't know it seems like you're seems
prideful to use that term
but i appreciate the mention nonetheless
you're devout catholic i need your
opinion on this i'm mormon i'm dating a
catholic girl and both of us are very
serious about our own religious beliefs
we're getting serious about our
relationship and talking about marriage
what do we do we don't want to end our
relationship but most importantly
we don't want to stop the current
relationship we separately have with god
in our own religions could we make it
work since we are both christian
we are especially worried about what we
would teach our kids if we were married
thank you for having the best show on
the daily wire thank you very much
appreciate the question
i've got bad news for you i'm not going
to sugarcoat it
it is you cannot get married in if you
are a catholic
if you do not agree to raise the kids
catholic it is
you you won't be permitted to do it you
could
get an interfaith dispensation from the
bishop to marry outside of the catholic
faith
but only if you agree to raise the
children catholic
so just as a practical matter unless
your wife wants to give up her catholic
faith
she cannot marry you unless you raise
the kids catholic now if you raise the
kids catholic
uh that would raise the next question of
well why maybe you should just be
catholic too
if the whole family is going to be
catholic because it would be very
difficult for
you to be the head of your household
which presumably you will be
to lead your family if your entire
family practices a different faith
than you do there's also regarding the
incompatibility of the religions
uh i mean i guess every religion is
incompatible with every other religion
in the sense that they're all different
but
but in particular there's a difference
with mormonism because
the catholic church is trinitarian which
which means that that
we believe that god is three distinct
persons in one divine unity
and the mormon church is not trinitarian
so they believe that that god the father
and this i mean you know better than i
do but god the father and god the son
and the holy spirit are separate beings
and i know that seems like a subtle
distinction but it has huge
theological implications the the trinity
is the central mystery
of christianity and and so if you're
unitarian
or an aryan or
uh mormon or or muslim for that matter
islam would have similar kinds of issues
then those two will not be able to mesh
now i would say
don't necessarily give up uh when
i i when my wife and i started dating we
had very different views not just from
one another but different views even
from what we currently have
now people grow either they grow
together or they grow apart so
if if you're open to it i would
explore the catholic faith and see if
it's right for you
you know and uh and i i suspect your
your girlfriend has
explored mormonism maybe not uh you know
you know my
feeling on on this you know where i
stand and which one i think is true
uh but uh you might want to consider
that
and then uh you might you might be
surprised you might find that you're
convinced by some of those arguments
if not i i tell you i i have great
respect for
you both that you take your faith so
seriously that you would prioritize it
even over
your romantic life that's very difficult
um
and i think it's wise if you are to take
your faith seriously
then it won't work
you can't you can't do those those
things separately forever
it will cause huge problems and and more
likely what would happen
is you will come together into a to a
single or similar faith
but if that faith might not be mormonism
or catholicism it might just be a kind
of liberal
secularism where you know you you don't
take religion very seriously and that
would be a choice as well
and i don't know that that would be a
great choice uh you're you're in a tough
position but
excellent that you you both have the
integrity to look the problem head-on so
that you're on more problems down the
road
from mike to the excellent michael
knowles i went to a halloween party this
weekend and had a fantastic
pun costume picture attached and he's
wearing
a gift box and it says two women from
god
it's a great costume it was a huge hit
at the party as we were obviously among
those people with common sense and a
great sense of humor
then on monday i saw an email at work
requesting that we share our halloween
costumes for the office costume contest
uh-oh
here we go then i got an email a couple
hours later due to the current social
climate
we can't allow the gift costume to enter
as is
he's free to blur out the tag and
resubmit
the current social club we mean the
current social climate you mean
political correctness which
very few people actually like but
unfortunately political correctness runs
corporate boardrooms
hr the university and government so
because of that
you're not allowed to have a very basic
costume what do you think is wrong with
the costume of anything
why must the left destroy all that is
fun and clever feel free to share
yours truly from a fellow paisano yeah
obviously nothing's wrong
with the costume it's very funny it's
actually tongue-in-cheek right i mean
the idea that you are god's gift to
women you're not it's not you're not
making an earnest statement it's a
self-effacing joke but you're not
allowed to do that anymore
the reason for this is that political
correctness uh people get it wrong
a lot political correctness some people
think is
uh a speech just a speech code if it's a
speech code it's politically correct but
that's not true
everyone has speech codes every society
and all of human history has had speech
codes conservatives have speech codes
too
that's not the issue some people say
political correctness is euphemism
it's using you know kind of soft words
to paper over difficult truths
political correctness includes euphemism
but we all use euphemism when we refer
to
a woman of a certain age instead of an
old hag
we're using euphemism and they're
perfectly legitimate uses
for euphemism political correctness is
a totalizing left-wing standard
to overturn the old standards
it is it is a negative standard like
you'd call it
an anti-standard standard
it's a way to say okay here are all the
traditional opinions and prejudices and
i use that term neutrally not in the
sense of bigoted and here are all the
traditional mores
and rituals that we have in society and
political correctness comes in and says
we're going to reverse all of them
so traditionally in society men and
women are considered
different and complementary so political
correctness comes in and says no no
men and women are exactly the same
they're identical
and this is a an article of faith for
the politically correct and that's the
specific issue
that you're having with your costumers
what you're saying is men and women are
different we approach life differently
we approach sex differently we approach
the tr the other sex differently and uh
that is not allowed you're not you're
not allowed to mention those differences
between men and women and
that's just the way it is we're living
in a politically correct regime
we thought that we were living in a
relatively s
right of center conservative democracy
we're not we're living in a liberal
technocracy
and uh and we will submit we will have
to submit that is the lesson from the
election let's try to take one more
question before we go because i know
there are a lot of questions coming in
from sarah i have a serious question the
media have repeated over and over again
how great it would be to have a female
president do you think it would be a net
benefit to have the next president be
female
thanks well if the next president is
kamala harris then certainly not
that would be very very negative but
then broadly
do you think it would be good for the
country do you think it would be a
positive
for the country if we were to elect a
woman president next
no of course not why what would the
positive thing be what what specifically
about being a woman
is so much better than being a man that
it would be
positive to make any woman president
right now
what would what would that be i can't
think of anything the left
believes that there would be something
positive because they view the past as
oppressive
we don't view the past as oppressive
conservatives view the past as the past
you know and some periods are good some
periods are less good
the present right now might not be all
it's cracked up to be might be better
than other periods though in the future
who knows how it's going to turn out
and there is wisdom that we can gain
from the past
and we can conserve the good the
objective good
through those traditions that's a
wonderful thing to do
but the past itself is not a pro but
what the left does they look at the past
and they say okay
past empowered men men are oppressive
and awful and white people are
oppressive and
awful and so anything
that is not male and not white has to be
good
has to be better than what we've got i
don't think that's true
maybe maybe some woman would be better
than some man could be
but i don't know you got to show me the
woman i don't i don't see who that woman
would be
and it sure ain't kamala harris but
kamal harris may be our next vice
president which means
more than likely she could be our next
president
a lot of people are giving up already
i'm not willing to give up
i don't think that this process has been
above board and i don't think the trump
campaign thinks this process has been
above board
and i think most republicans would have
rolled over right now and given it all
up
and fortunately trump hasn't done that
and i would strongly encourage the trump
campaign
not to give up fight this thing tooth
and nail
this is a travesty what's going on it's
an embarrassment to the country
what leftists are doing right now that
the greatest democracy in the world
can't even conduct its own election
because of shenanigans involving mail-in
ballots
and delayed poll numbers that's
disgusting
they should be very ashamed of it and we
shouldn't let them get away with it
no matter how the final count turns out
we cannot let them get away with what
they're doing right now
i'm michael knowles this is the michael
knowles show keep the faith i'll see you
on monday
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer
jeremy boring our technical director is
austin stevens
supervising producers mathis glover and
robert sterling
assistant director pavel wadowski editor
and associate producer
danny d'amico audio mixer robin
fenderson
hair and makeup nika geneva and
production assistant
ryan love the michael knowles show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 20.
if you prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle well tune in to the
ben shapiro show we'll get a whole lot
of that
and much more see you there